Yeah right yeah not sure that we much
great can we do so last month we had a
workshop here on logic symmetry
computation I gave a talk there on
certain tests for graph isomorphism and
at the end of that talk I made a remark
linking it to certain you know
constraint satisfaction problems and
make made a little jokey reference to
Prakash is slogan of category five so
this talk is really an expansion of that
remark into 20 minutes but this doesn't
mean it's a follow-up you don't need to
know anything about the the previous
talk to follow this so I know some of
you some number of you were there for
that one I see its joint work with
penguin Wang this this is a non
completed piece of work it's more some
ideas here and I have discussed peg me
wearing my PhD student and he's
currently writing up his PhD thesis so
some of this will appear in there but it
doesn't appear as a published piece of
work yet okay
so we're in the realm of finite more
theory so I'm assuming we have some fix
finite relational vocabulary so a
sequence of relation symbols each with
an Associated arity and I'm going to
talk about finite towel structures
meaning structure consists of a finite
set and an interpretation for each
relation symbol has a relation over the
set ok yeah just what it says I mean you
view I don't think it makes any it
doesn't hurt but for this purpose no for
simplicity of exposition no let's put it
that way okay as a special case you can
always keep in mind when we have a
single relation of binary in which case
our structures are simply finite
directed graphs okay right we have the
notion of hormone morphism between
structures so a homomorphism is exactly
what you would expect of course a
function from the universe of A to B
which preserves all the relations so for
any tuple so bold face is a tuple my
bold face is working this time and if
it's in a relation in a particular
relation a its image is in the
corresponding interpretation of the
relation in be an isomorphism means the
usual right there is a bijection and now
this this is an F and only if okay and
of course I mean this is simply the
category of finite tau structures and so
we can alternatively define isomorphism
as the existence of a pair of
homomorphisms which are mutually inverse
right so the compositions give you the
identities on the two ok this is if you
will be the motivating picture now from
the point of view of algorithmics these
are two rather different problems right
we have a problem of deciding given for
a and B whether there exists a
homomorphism this is well known NP
complete problem it appears in many
different guises as we've seen over time
I mean
database theory this is conjunctive
query containment this in AI this goes
by the name of the constraint
satisfaction problem so it's NP complete
even for sometimes when you fix the
structure be depending upon which
structure this problem may be
np-complete but we're thinking of it in
general it is in this one the problem of
deciding given a nd whether there's an
isomorphism between them on the other
hand as a rather different status it's
not known to be np-complete though it is
known to be NP I mean we it's not not to
be in P and essentially by popeyes
result of four graphs this will you it
is essentially in Kwazii polynomial time
for finite relation structures generally
and therefore I mean there's already
plenty of evidence that it's not NP
complete but this we can also take as
very strong evidence but this problem is
not in P complete it's a looks like it's
somewhere in between okay well but still
it a quasi polynomial time is still
pretty bad in practice there are lots of
algorithms which approximate these two
in one way or another and I want to talk
about particular one I'm not going to
describe the algorithm in detail but the
K local consistency test is way of
testing for homomorphism it's not
guaranteed to succeed in the sense that
it might tell you that these two are
consistent which if they're homomorphic
if there is a homomorphism there will be
but if the you know they can be
consistent even in the absence of a
homomorphism k is an integer parameter
here and the algorithm runs in time and
to the order K so the higher the K the
worse the running time but the finer the
test so the idea roughly speaking k
local consistency means I look at a
window in a of size K and see if I can
map it homo more quickly on to be and I
move this window around seeing whether I
can extend the map but obviously i'm
dropping other elements because i never
keep a window size bigger than k and i
move the window around essentially all
over a seeing whether i can
locally extend the homomorphism in B
that's the local consistency test
roughly speaking it has a connection to
logic mainly we consider existential
positive formulas of first-order logic
so first order logic positive means
navigation and existential means only
existential quantifiers positive doesn't
apply the existing sure sorry that's a
remark to Prakash and we restrict
ourselves to using no more than K
distinct variables okay for example i
can write down a formula which says in a
graph that there exists a cake leak they
exist k elements pairwise their distinct
I users using only care variables it's
only existential or positive no
negations but I can't say that there is
AK plus 1 click that would require k
plus 1 variables okay on the other hand
look at this I want to see there's a
path of length n for some margin I can
do the just using two variables and no
more because I say there's a pair of
points x1 x2 with an edge and then there
is some x1 I reuse the variable which is
a such that there's an edge from x0 x1
etc etc so the long formula using just
two variables I can do it let's see how
many just to sort of stress the
difference between these two examples
if I have a key k plus one click and a
cake leak there's no homomorphism
between them you can't map it
homomorphic Lee but this pair of
structures will pass the k local
consistency test because if i look at
any window size k it Maps homomorphic
you and I can move the window around and
I can always change the homomorphism to
make it work if i have a path of length
n plus 1 and a path of length n direct
directed path again I can't rapid
homomorphic Lee but now I can detect
this failure with a simple local
consistency check you start with this
you map it homomorphic Lee anywhere and
then just move this window length to
along the path and you'll eventually run
out of space over here and you
distinguish them okay so here to local
consistency establishes the non
isomorphism here it doesn't okay now
this right this relation to say that you
know when a and B we have a que lo que
local consistency map or but was it more
formally for any sentence of existential
parts of logic using only care variables
if it's true in a it's ruined be okay
and so the algorithmically the K local
consistency test is a test for this
relation clearly if I take k to be big
enough say the size of a then that's
equivalent to saying there's a
homomorphism for smaller values of K
this implies it but not not necessarily
the other way around
there's a nice characterization of this
relation in terms of pebble games I
think I've got the date right all right
it's 1990 okay right starting to do this
from memory okay there's nice
characterization in terms of pebble
games so we have a pair of structures
and B and we have two players called
spoiler and duplicator and we have K
pairs of pebbles which I'll call a won't
be on a play k BK and in this version of
the game spoiler always chooses one of
these days a one two AK and puts it on
an element of the structure a duplicator
has to respond by putting the other
element the other matching pebble on an
element of B okay and this game can
continue for more than K moves so the
pebbles move once their cave on the
spoiler has to pick one up and move it
somewhere else etc at any stage if the
partial map from the pebbled elements of
a to the matching pebble elements of V
is not a homomorphism of the induced
substructures spoiler has one spoiler
has demonstrated the difference the K
local consistency test has failed and if
duplicator has a strategy to play
without forever without losing then the
structures pass so a is a br in this
relation okay
well we can think of composing
strategies so if duplicator has a
winning strategy where a and B
structures envy and a winning strategy
strategy bill and B and C there's an
actual way to compose these winning
strategies right to get a strategy boone
NC mainly spoiler so we have a game
between a and C duplicate in those
winning strategies for both of these
whenever spoiler plays in a you choose
the response in the strategy over here
now treat that as a spoiler move choose
the response of duplicator in C and take
that as a response to the original movie
name that's a nice informal description
formalizing it I mean it's not too
difficult but I'm just going to try and
do this a bit carefully so I'm going to
find a strategy for this game as a set
of parents so that we're so think of
these pairs as possible positions in the
game so they are l tuples of elements
for some value of l between 0 and k ok
the value of L varies from 2.2 tuple
right I'm what I mean it's L is not
fixed or H so and we have certain
properties namely it's sort of downward
closed whenever you have a pair in H
eliminating corresponding elements of
the tuple still gives you a pair in H ok
this it means that basically you can
remove a pair of doubles in the game and
then the extension property if you have
a pair of tuples of length strictly less
than k then there's an extension maybe a
function from A to B so that the
extension of the pupil with a and B with
FFA gives you all of them are tuples in
h ok now
this well when I write the definition
now it seems slightly unsatisfactory
because I call i'm calling this a
strategy but in its not doesn't give you
a strategy in the way we usually think
of it because i'm not saying this
functions unique right so it doesn't
tell you what duplicator has to do it
just says there is something duplicator
can do so it's not a strategy in this
sense so we if we try and say actually
we could try and formalize the notion of
strategy as something which for any
position gives you a particular function
that leads us into some a bit of a
difficulty which is may be best
explained in this picture so suppose we
have a fixed strategy namely for any
position here a function which maps to
this and for any position be windy and
see a function that that gives us the
next move it's not clear how do you how
you compose those because given a
position bill in a and C there are many
ways you could factor it into a position
where a b and b c and those factors
could give you different functions okay
and there isn't there is nothing in the
definition here that enforces
consistency of those different functions
so instead we define a strategy to just
be a set of positions with this closure
properties and this guarantees that in
some sense it contains a strategy right
that there is somewhere in there a
function okay and the point of this is
this now allows a nice no notion of
composition we also have a notion of
identity strategy so we've got ourselves
a category okay
I would say we are call a strategy
injective if it satisfies this and in
condition to you can always choose the
function f to be objective ok and I'll
sometimes to note that I didn't put it
on this slide with a little subscript on
on this relation symbol for inject
effects ok with that we get a nice
little thing we can prove so the
following are equivalent for any parent
structures this is the usual notion of
isomorphism in the category of I've just
defined right so there's a pair of
strategies which which are mutually
inverse this is equivalent to simply a
pair of injector strategies in both
directions ok and this is equivalent to
the existence of a bioactive strategy
from A to B ok and the reason this is
nice is because this number 3 condition
is something sort of which arises very
naturally in an entirely different way
if this is essentially winning condition
for something else called the bijection
game which is introduced by Heba and it
was introduced by Hannah as a
characterization for a a certain
counting logic ok so tell us by ejection
game characterize a certain is a certain
equivalence relation which i call k
equivalents which says the two
structures can be distinguished by any
sentence of k variable first or logical
counting quantifiers now this is sort of
a versatile was kind of independent
interest and have i introduced the
bisection game for analyzing this at way
which was used for analyzing certain
fixed point logics with counting here
this equivalence just falls out as the
notion of isomorphism in the category we
of strategies we defined and this
equivalence relation turns out to have
many independent characterisations I
mentioned by ejection games I've
mentioned these you know counting
quantifiers logic it has an entirely
combinatorial characterization which is
well-known from Baba's organize a
morphism yeah basically this K
equivalent for pair of graphs is the
same as saying that they can't be
distinguished by what's called the K
minus 1 dimensional viceroy element
method
which is a well-studied approximation of
graph isomorphism right again it gives
you an algorithm for for grass of an
approximation of graph isomorphism for
any fixed value of K and well we know
that there's no fixed value of K for
which it gives you all of isomorphism
that's the famous I for a moment result
okay
ok so this so far so it's kind of a nice
observation that defining this k local
consistency in terms of strategies which
we can compose allows this nice
independently well studied notion of
equivalents to fall out what can we do
with this well we don't quite know yet
one thing we looked at I mean now
essentially looking at classically
what's what we know about the category
of structures under homomorphisms well
we you know what can we reproduce in
this in this framework we look at the
notion of a core so a structure is
called a core if it has no proper
retract right so no proper structure on
sub structure on to which it Maps
homomorphic lee we know that every
structure contains a core right ah and
moreover its unique applies amorphous oh
ok every finite structure yeah very
first slide or all my structures of
finite ok so so every structure has a
core and its unique up to isomorphism
and now we can reproduce this you know
what does this mean in the category we
have just defined so we say that a prime
is a cake or of a if it satisfies the
following conditions it maps k locally
to it sorry a map scale Oakley to a
prime
right so we replaced the homomorphism
condition with k local consistency what
happens to the substructure condition
well the same that a prime is the
substructure phase just to say that
there's an injective homomorphism from a
to a so this becomes a prime maps
injective leak a locally into a and we
want a minimality condition which turns
into this for any structure which do it
a map scale locally and which maps
injective leak a locally to be then a
prime apps injective Lee halo clean to
be that's the minimal d condition and
then we can show that every structure
has a cake or and its unique up to the
ck Poland's okay okay Coleman's right
the be rejected games I mean I think
there's a lot more you could do just in
terms of looking above at natural
properties in this in this category of
formal morphisms and reproducing them
here would be to say a promise of
retract this is the first condition
exactly yes and I I did say that
verbally it's not on the side but I did
say we tracked yes okay now when we
started doing these definitions we were
after something we would like to prove
which we still don't or approve so I
mean I'll end with a few questions this
is I mean for those of you who around at
the beginning of the semester penguin
gave a talk about an open preservation
theorem he'd like to prove this is a
version of that statement you may not
recognize it as such if we have a class
of start finite structures which is
closed under K equivalents and closed
under homomorphisms is it closed under K
local consistency or let's say k prime
for some K prime ok this is if
reformulation of the preservation
theorem the penguin wings and this was
actually what we were motivated by we
were looking at this in in formulating
this but so far we don't know how to use
this reform relation to get anywhere
with this
the other sorts of things we looking at
as and this is what I mentioned at the
at the end of my talk in the cemetery
workshop this is sort of a pair of dual
questions we have other ways of
approximating homomorphism other than K
local consistency there are lots of sort
of these algebraic constraint
satisfaction algorithms what sort of
utilize and represent X could you
extract from those and conversely
there's lots of isomorphism tests unlike
the Vice rather layman based on sort of
group theoretic algorithms or like the
ones I talked about before in the last
workshop about you know based on
invertible in your maps and again there
seems to be a useful yes right I'm
extending the tuple area with Alma day
and the tuple be with the element of a
what should question the function a just
well I'm saying for every pair there is
a function so o.o its separate for each
yes so do you same way ok ok junction
the seventies keeker had the notion of
core
the chorus he defined it may not exist
on infant grabs take just a straight
line via keep it even prove it exists
always but there was enough I know okay
I don't know that no see this beautiful
about the name no but this name comes
from a series give clear yes this is
from well certainly inherent Nationals
book which is from 1990 it says but but
but a paper by hearing as it is from the
80s a deserter but he almost agree and
what about computing the cake or
computing the chorus amplified when the
welcome to do a cake or so I don't know
the thing the thing about the cake or is
that unlike the core the cake or doesn't
have to be a substructure of a all right
we've replaced the structure
substructure condition with this but I
suppose you could actually because of
the injectivity condition you know that
it's no bigger than a so it's going to
be an NP that's for sure hardness I
don't know I don't know all right
[Applause]